[Musik]
es ist eine wohnkrise die wir in
Deutschland erleben die Kosten für das
eigene Häuschen die drohen zu
explodieren und bezahlbaren
Mietwohnungen in den Städten vor allen
Dingen in den Großstädten die werden
immer knapper und noch knapper was davon
kosten darüber diskutieren wir jetzt
hier bei Bild mit diesem Gästen nämlich
mit Daniel Fürst dem Wohnungsbau
Experten der FDP im Bundestag
den Vorstand des Deutschen Mieterbundes
Markus Becker ist bei uns
Geschäftsführer von Condor Wessels das
ist einer der größten wohnungsbauer bei
uns im Land und übrigens
Autor von Immobilien Poker der hat sich
den Traum von einer Eigentumswohnung in
Berlin erfüllt aus dem Traum wurde
allerdings leider wir gleich erfahren
werden ein Albtraum dass die Gäste jetzt
hier bei Bild die richtigen Fragen jedes
Jahr
100.000 neue Wohnungen das hat sich ihre
Regierung als Ziel gesetzt
Koalitionsvertrag wo stehen wir da
aktuell wir sind völlig zu Recht wie von
ihnen formuliert in einer wohnkrise
nichtsdestotrotz brauchen wir diese
400.000 Wohnungen ist ja keine Zahlen
die man sich so wo stehen wir jetzt
400.000 war vorgenommen jedes Jahr
die Situation ist nicht gut das weiß
jeder wir sind ich weiß nicht die
aktuellen Zahlen bei 250.000 50 also
weiter von entfernt die 4000 zu
erreichen was ja eigentlich nur zur
Folge hat dass die Politik noch sehr
viel stärker agieren muss um diese
400.000 zu erreichen weil das keine Zahl
ist die man sich auswürfelt sondern das
ist der minimale Bedarf die wird jedes
Jahr brauchen deswegen ist es ja nicht
unerheblich das genau auch zu wissen wo
wir aktuell stehen wenn sie sagen so
über einen Daumen gepeil sind wir da
150.000 etwa der hinterher das war ein
Versprechen dass auch sie mit abgegeben
haben deswegen arbeiten wir auch jeden
Tag in der Ampel daran wir treiben das
Bauministerium will erwarten dass mehr
passiert wir haben als FDP-Fraktion noch
ein eigenes Papier vorgelegt mit 11
schnell zu ergreifenden Maßnahmen zum
Beispiel ein Dachausbau fördern
Bürokratie abbauen und das ein oder
andere im förderdings Punkt ist wir
brauchen den Content dass wir diese
Wohnungen bauen und dann müssen auch die
Grünen einschlagen wenn wir die Wohnung
nicht bauen
können bevor Sie anfangen zu regieren
Herr wählt jetzt sitzt hier der mit am
Tisch der das mit seiner Regierung
vertritt dieses Versprechen 400 000 neue
Wohnungen jetzt hör mal liegt wieder
weiter hinter zurück und er sagt wir
arbeiten daran dass es dahin kommt das
bedeutet ja man muss jetzt die
Folgejahre ja drei Jahr vier 600 000
700.000 schaffen um das überhaupt wieder
aufzuholen was denken glauben Sie unsere
Zuschauer was denken die Mieter in dem
Moment die möglicherweise in diese
Wohnung hätten einziehen können also
erstmal kann ich jeder Mieter in jede
neue Wohnung einziehen das ist eine ganz
wichtige Informationen weil die Wohnung
die geschaffen werden sind ja nur
begrenzt für breite Schichten der
Bevölkerung auch beziehbar das heißt
Luxuswohnung teure Wohnungen sind große
Wohnungen der Anteil der preisgün
eigenen Wohnung liegt bei ungefähr 15
Prozent in der Regel das von Kommune zu
Kommune etwas unterschiedlich ich halte
das für Fiktionen solche Zahlen in die
Welt zu setzen natürlich konnte keiner
wissen dass wir den ukrainekrieg haben
und das konnte auch keiner schon
Inflation in baukostenanstieg
vorhersagen aber 400.000 Wohnungen war
auch ohne diese Geschichte eine riesig
ehrgeizige Ziel und aus meiner Sicht in
dieser Summe für die Bevölkerung die am
ehesten auf Wohnung angewiesen ist auch
gar nicht notwendig sage ich ganz
ehrlich uns kommt es darauf an vor allen
Dingen preisgünstigen Wohnungsbau zu
errichten weil diese Menschen am Markt
sich ebenso gut nicht bedienen können
während Familien oder Haushalte mit
höheren Einkommen in der Regel auch
etwas finden wenn sie durch Berlin gehen
beispielsweise dann finden sie teilweise
Quartiere wo wenn sie da mal am
Wochenende sind am Samstag kein einziges
Lichtlein brennt weil viele ihre Zeit
oder dritte Wohnung hier haben da gibt
da wird auch ziemlich viel Unsinn gebaut
deswegen aus unserer Sicht müssen wir
auch im Hinblick auf den Klimaschutz das
ist ja auch eine Aufgabe der
Bundesregierung sehr wohl aufpassen was
wir mit der Bauindustrie machen und da
meine ich müssen wir konzentrieren
konzentrieren auf die wichtigen Sachen
das diskutieren wir gleich ein Bild
lassen uns einmal bei diesen 400.000
bleiben wo sie jetzt sagen ist
vielleicht gar nicht so wichtig weil nur
ein kleiner Teil davon hätte wirklich
der breiten Masse der Bevölkerung der
den den Menschen die nicht
Luxuswohnungen suchen geholfen wie viele
Menschen gerade in diesen niedrigeren
mittleren Einkommen suchen aktuell
wohnen also wir schätzen den jährlichen
Bedarf auf 150 bis 100 bis 200.000 an
diesen Wohnungen die für breite
Schichten der Bevölkerung beziehbar
wären das haben wir schon erreicht wenn
man so will 250.000 Wohnungen aber die
Wohnung die errichtet worden sind die
sind eben nicht verbreite Schichten der
Bevölkerung sondern wir haben zum
Beispiel im sozialen Wohnungsbau ich
glaube 27.000 Wohnungen in 2021
errichten lassen das sind natürlich
Haushalte mit geringem Einkommen und das
sicher zu wenig und wo fehlt da
besonders also nur in den Großstädten
oder trifft die Fläche das Problem ist
weniger die regionale Verortung na klar
es ist vor allen Dingen da wo die
Nachfrage hoch ist da brauchen wir die
Wohnung das gar keine Frage aber also
der Städte mit Universitäten
aber eins ist auf jeden Fall klar was
wir dafür brauchen für diesen
Wohnungsbau sind ja Grundstücke das ist
die erste Klammer sozusagen die gelöst
werden muss und da haben wir ein Problem
nehmen Sie Berlin innerhalb des S-Bahn
Ringes wo die Nachfrage besonders hoch
ist sind ganze 11% in öffentliche Hand
das ist ein Problem weil sozialen
Wohnungsbau kann man auf diesen privaten
Grundstücken nur dann errichten wenn wir
in solchen Kooperation baulandmodell
Vereinbarung mit privaten Treffen die
ein Teil soziale Wohnungsbau errichten
sonst kommen wir überhaupt nicht zum
sozialwohnungsbau das ist ein zentrales
Problem also wo sind die Grundstücke wie
können die Kommunen die Grundstücke
bereithalten das sind ihre viele Fehler
gemacht worden machen sie sich das in
ihrem politischen Alltag vielleicht
nicht ausreichen bewusst was es bedeutet
Wohnungs so zu haben ey natürlich ich
bin übrigens aus der Familienpolitik zur
Wohnungspolitik gekommen weil ich mir
nicht mehr erklären konnte wie sich
Familien in großen Städten des wohnen
leisten können die Wohnkosten sind
massiver massiver Triebfeder in der
Ampel ich muss leider ein paar Sachen
korrigieren es tut mir leid die Bedarf
150.000 im Jahr ist viel zu niedrig die
Wissenschaft geht von 400 bis 700.000
aus plus das was wir brauchen für die
Flüchtlinge also wir müssen diesen
Wohnraum schaffen natürlich muss er
günstig sein aber auch der Begriff wir
brauchen dafür ein freies Grundstück auf
den wir irgendwas bauen ist auch
veraltet wir müssen es Bau Potential
schöpfen Umbau Ausbau daraufstockung
Umnutzung muss ein Hotel immer Hotel
sein oder kann es auch ein
Studentenwohnheim sein wir müssen
wegkommen von der Vorstellung eine
Wohnung kann nur auf eine grünen Fläche
entstehen wir müssen schauen was für
Potenzial es gibt und da gibt es in der
Dach Aufstockung alleine in Deutschland
laut Wissenschaft bis zu 1 Million
Wohnungen Potential und die zu heben da
bin ich dabei das ist Aufgabe der
Regierung die Regelungsrahmen zu setzen
und das machen wir Bäcker sie bauen
hier wie niemand anderes hier bei uns am
Tisch das ist nämlich ihr Job für Condor
westedt sie bauen bauen bauen aber sie
bauen zu wenig warum
wir bauen sich ja noch nicht zu wenig
aber wir wir könnten die Zahlen die hier
aufgerufen werden als Bauindustrie gerne
bauen wir wollen die Wohnung gerne bauen
wir wollen
kostengünstige Wohnungen also die
150.000 von denen Herr wild spricht sind
ja kostengünstige Wohnung was ist eine
kostengünstige Wohnung da kostengünstige
Wohnungen sind sind mieten für für mich
die oder wo die Wohnungsbau Kosten
Herstellkosten um die 3000 € pro
Quadratmeter Wohnfläche liegen das ist
heute der Preis für eine
kostengünstigung ein Jahr zurück was
1000 € weniger es muss man sagen da
waren die Kosten günstigen Wohnung für
2000 € zu bauen die kann man bauen die
kann man auf Google auf Grundstücken
bauen die natürlich die Kommunen zur
Verfügung stellen sollten und dann
kriegen auch die Kunden von Herrn wild
oder die die
vertreten er will die kriegen dann auch
ihre Wohnung die preisgünstigen aber
wenn die Kommunen weiterhin von uns
verlangen 30 Prozent Sozialwohnungen für
sechs Euro 50 zu bauen das halten wir
nicht aus weil einer übersetzt für das
was wir eigentlich brauchen in der Stadt
speziell in Berlin bezahlbare Mieten da
sagen sie das lohnt sich einfach für uns
überhaupt gar nicht diese Wohnung dazu
mieten
für uns lohnt sich diese Wohnung zu
bauen und wir verdienen insofern ja
nicht weil wir nicht die
Wohnungsbaugesellschaften sind dies
vermieden sondern wir sind die
Bauindustrie die es baut und wir können
Neubau zu erträglichen Preisen
Grundstückspreisen für 12 bis 14 € in
dieser Stadt vermieten das ist einfach
die die die Tatsache und wir kriegen ja
weiterhin als herstellende
Wohnungswirtschaft
Daseinsvorsorge des Staates aufgebürdet
wir müssen 80.000 € pro Stunde
Stellplatz bezahlen wir müssen
Kindergarten stell unterstütze ablesen
wir müssen Artenschutz um
Investitionen tätigen wir müssen
Ersatzpflanzungen vornehmen warum muss
man das tun wenn man günstige Wohnungen
haben will wenn man den Fokus auf
absolut kostengünstigen Wohnungsbau hier
sitzt einer der Verantwortlichen
absolute
Bürokratieabbau Partei und jetzt das
also nicht nicht alles was
Regelungsrahmen ist ist auf Bundesebene
geregelt aber es ist schon richtig wir
haben verlernt günstig zu bauen weil wir
ständig neue Anforderungen machen die
Kommune liegt noch was oben drauf dann
liegt das Land oder was oben drauf und
dann liegt erhabig noch was oben drauf
wir müssen wieder zurückkommen dass wir
günstig bauen weil wir günstig baut kann
auch günstiger vermieten tatsächlich
sind manche externe Schocks die kann die
Politik auch nicht heilen also die
Energiekosten sind ein Problem auf wenn
wir gegen arbeiten die werden auch
wieder nachlassen die Lieferketten der
kriegt das Wasser verteuert wurde da
können wir auch politisch nicht
gegensteuern aber was wir machen müssen
und auch können und das auch die Debatte
die wir mit baumisierung führen wir
müssen bauen günstiger machen einfach
machen und schneller machen
Digitalisierung des Bauens der Antrag
dauert heute oft länger als der die
Baumaßnahme wie absurd ist das eine neue
Erkenntnis Herr Bäcker oder ist das
genau das Thema über das wir eigentlich
seit 30 40 Jahren streiten in
Deutschland absolut also das über
überhaupt nichts Neues ich bin jetzt
seit circa zehn Jahren den alten
möglichen
baukostensenkungskommission Bezeichnung
Weise auch mit Herrn wild immer zusammen
wir bespielen die gleichen Protagonisten
mit unterschiedlichen parteilichen
Farben die uns da begleiten aber die
Dinge die zum günstigen bauen für diese
waren vor 10 Jahren genau die gleichen
wie sie die heute sind und reden über
diese Themen und keiner löste
Regelung der regelungswahn der Politik
immer wieder Dämmstoff Bomber zu bauen
wir nennen dämmstoffröhre immer
effektiver immer immer weniger CO2
natürlichen Heere Ziel wunderbar wir
unterstützen durch alle was wir mehr
einbauen dürfen in die Häuser dafür
machen wir mehr Umsatz als Baufirmen das
ist so einfach aber die Dinge die liegen
klar geschafft daheim sie profitieren
sogar noch von Teilen der Bürokratie
ärgern sich zwar weil alles länger
dauert am Ende machen sie beim Teil
ihres Profils damit also ein System das
unter untereinander ganz gut
funktioniert aber keines der Probleme im
Land oder muss man überhaupt
das ist einfach wenn wir an einer Stelle
ein Haus bauen mit mir Anforderungen
denn bauen wir natürlich lieber mit mehr
Anforderungen als mit weniger
Anforderungen aber wir können sehr gut
mit weniger Anforderungen bauen aber wir
dürfen es nicht und da wäre den
bahnbrechen wenn die Politik sich da mal
durchsetzen würde und aufhören würde
immer wieder noch eine Anforderung noch
eine Anforderungen die Politik wird das
doch längste und der Fürst nimmt immer
schön neben ihm wird das ja längster
erkannt haben
muss es lösen und warum wird das bisher
nicht gelöst wenn doch die Erkenntnisse
klar ist
ja wir haben inzwischen wenn wir einen
Gipfel herbei rufen für kostengünstigen
Wohnungsbau nehmen wir hier in Berlin
Frau Giffey die sich sicherlich
vorbildlich für kostengünstigen
Wohnungsbau einsetzen möchte die damit
auch versucht hat die Wahl zu gewinnen
ist nicht ganz gelungen aber
trotzdem holen Sie 30 40 Protagonisten
an den Tisch wo die wenigsten davon
Ahnung von baukostensenkung haben die
allerwenigsten aber alle Meinungen
müssen eingespielt werden in so einem
Gipfel weil man ja politisch arbeitet
weil Frau Wähler Stimmen braucht und die
führt nicht je mehr verderben also
Politik die bisher dafür nicht
abgestraft wird wir haben
Wohnungsbauunternehmen die in letzter
Konsequenz ganz gut damit leben und
möglicherweise auch noch ganz gut daran
verdienen und wir haben eine große Masse
an Menschen die Wohnungen sucht die auch
gerne günstig bauen möchte die das aber
nicht kann und das Problem wird doch
nicht gelöst also das Problem ist leider
auch wirklich sehr schwierig zu lösen
erstmal ist das schon darauf hingewiesen
worden wir haben Bauordnung die sind
Ländersache damit geht schon los aber
die bilden der Anforderungen ab die
viele auch für richtig finden nehmen wir
mal den Brandschutz oder nehmen sie
klimaschutzanforderungen da sind ja
Dinge die auch gesellschaftlich sinnvoll
ist wofür man auch steht ich will ja
nicht bestreiten dass da viel
Überflüssiges auch dabei ist und vor
allem die Dauer der Prozesse in den
Entscheidungen dies muss natürlich
eigentlich so lang sein alles trifft ja
nicht nur den Frage der Bauordnung der
Genehmigung sondern trifft auch die
Frage der Förderung natürlich wenn das
Personal nicht da ist und die
Kapazitäten der Förderstellen nicht da
sind sie warten noch heute wenn sie bei
der BAFA einen Antrag stellen ein Jahr
bis eine Genehmigung bekommen das ist
das bis zussamen ein Jahr wenn sie
solche Prozesse natürlich haben dann
dauert es einfach viel zu lange und dann
ist ein Bauvorhaben auch dort aber
nehmen Sie den Klimaschutz und die
Anforderungen die wir da haben die sind
für uns doch alle genauso wichtig und
deswegen finde ich kann man nicht alles
schlecht reden was da ist ich finde auch
was aufgeräumt werden kann sollte
aufgeräumt werden das kann der Bund
wahrscheinlich zum großen Teil gar nicht
machen weil die Entscheidungen nämlich
in den Kommunen oder in den Ländern
fallen da ist was zu tun aber das nicht
das Problem wir haben ja über Jahre auch
sehr viel Wohnungsneubau gehabt und die
Unternehmen konnten diese Wohnung
herstellen wir haben das hier gehört was
geleistet werden kann und ich würde das
jetzt nicht einfach nur schlecht reden
gucken wir mal wir haben tatsächlich
sehr viele Neubau gehabt und ich stimme
ist an der Stelle zu wir müssen in der
Tat intelligenter noch sein und auch die
Bestände sozusagen anschauen was können
wir da generieren an Wohnraum nicht nur
bezüglich Dachgeschoss Ausbau sondern
eine bessere Nutzung nee habe und so
weiter aber das sind alles nur kleine
Punkte da wird man diese wahnsinnig viel
Geld gewinnen können gerade das Thema
vom Bauen und wir reden in dem
Zusammenhang sozusagen über das
Deutschland Tempo ich kann ihn verraten
wenn ich morgens aus dem Fenster schaue
dann schaue ich immer auf ein großes
Hochhaus hier in Berlin und da steht
seit Jahren mittlerweile alles still in
Berliner Südwesten in Steglitz
Steglitzer Kreisel und ein Mann der ja
genau da sie sehen das gerade liebe
Zuschauer das ist das Hochhaus dort
sollten ganz tolle über Berlin
liegende Eigentumswohnungen entstehen
und einer der hiermit am Tisch sitzt
andre Kaufer der hat genau davon auch
geträumt von einer solchen
Eigentumswohnung über den Dächern
Berlins
2018 haben sie gekauft
sind sie eingezogen nein es war ja auch
für meine Tochter gedacht und sollte
ursprünglich Ende 2000 die aber auch bei
weitem nicht wohnt richtig genau 2000
Ende 2021 fertig sein und wie wir alle
wissen steht das Grippe ja bis heute
noch so da dann tut sich nichts seit
2020 seit März 2020 und ähm
ich sehe auch nicht dass es fertig wird
wann sollte das eigentlich fertig sein
Ende 2021 Uhr also sie sollte längster
wohnen eigentlich ihre Tochter was ist
der Hauptgrund warum hat das so lange
gedauert warum herrscht auch da
Deutschland Tempo warum ist man da nicht
weiter das zum einen liegt es an einem
der landeseigenen Bau mobile man
Gesellschaft bin weil die als sie das
den Turm verkauft haben steht jetzt der
Kreisel an die cd-gruppe leider Gottes
nur eine einmalige Auflage hatte im
Vertrag nämlich dass wenn der Bau nicht
fristgerechtfertig gestellt wird
lediglich einmalig eine Million Euro als
Strafe zu zahlen ist und das ist
natürlich beim Projekt bei 200 Millionen
Euro für die Unternehmen wird das
gezahlt aus der Portokasse das ist
lächerlich und seitdem hat sozusagen
haben wir keine Handhabe mehr die Stadt
keine Hand habe mehr ja hier nun endlich
drauf zu kochen dass der steht jetzt der
Kreise fertig wird oder eben die
Möglichkeit besteht zurück zu erwerben
was jetzt eben auch nicht mehr geht das
bedeutet also dass der Objekt kann also
aus rein spekulationsgründen nach wie
vor ohne dass die Wohnung fertiggestellt
werden dort weiterhin stehen also der
Konzern in dem Fall die Adler Gruppe die
macht damit ganz gut Reinbach und Sie
können aber auf wahrscheinlich noch
Jahre hinaus ihre Tochter dort nicht
wohnen lassen richtig also nicht nur ich
sondern es geht ja um insgesamt 330
Wohnungen 130 sind verkauft worden und
viele warten darauf endlich einziehen zu
können oder vermieten zu können und das
sieht also bisher nicht danach aus das
heißt die Konzerne wollen als sich an
uns bereichern ja aber schaffen damit
keine Wohnfläche keinen Wohnraum sind
die Konzerne in dem Fall Schuld das ist
ja ein besonderer Fall der aber kein
Einzelfall gleichermaßen ist in
Deutschland für Deutschland Tempo in der
Zeit in der in China ganze Städte
hochgezogen werden da steht dieses
Hochhaus nach wie vor komplett leer und
es tut sich wirklich jeden Tag einfach
mal gar nichts wegen der Konzerne
wenn wir die adlergruppe da würde ich
mich ein bisschen dagegen wehren die zu
verallgemeinernden die haben schon eine
einzigartige Karriere hier in
Deutschland da gelegt und die haben für
uns alle eine dieser Größe Vorstellung
gegeben so dass eigentlich die gesamte
Branche darunter leidet und ist ja
extrem Vertrauensverlust bei bestimmten
Anlegern die dort einfach nur eine
Wohnung haben wollten also der Hauptteil
der Branche liefert die Wohnungen schon
wenn sie bestellt werden und die werden
nur fertig gebaut und das haben wir auch
gesehen dass in der jetzigen Krise die
Projekte die angefangen werden die
werden also zu 99,9% auf fertiggestellt
und was immer wieder vergessen wird der
gute Herr Habeck hat ja Anfang Januar
vorhin Jahres mal die KfW-Förderung
wegfallen lassen so quasi über Nacht
jedenfalls für mich und dann sind die
Zinsen dramatische stiegen und
nebenbaukostensteigerungen habe ich ja
auch gelernt dass alles was aus der
Ukraine kommt wird teurer selbst die
Zinsen kommen mehr aus der Ukraine weil
sie so extrem steigen und das ist
eigentlich der Grund warum der
Wohnungsmarkt zum Einschlafen gekommen
und adäquate Förderung gibt es nicht
nicht mehr also seitdem nie wieder was
adäquate dauert der Staat muss das jetzt
wieder ankurven damit das Geschäft
wieder in Gang kommt Herr Voest das was
sie bei der FDP eigentlich nicht so
gerne mögen immer weiter so
funktionieren subventionieren ist das im
Moment die Lösung für die Aufträge das
ist ja eigentlich unglaublich angesichts
der Lage auf dem Wohnungsmarkt gerade
zurückgehen also wir haben derzeit in
der kaffeeförderung für die Sanierung 15
Milliarden liegen und für den Neubau
etwas über eine Milliarde das ist weit
von dem was wir vorher hatten ich glaube
2022 waren über 30 Milliarden
tatsächlich brauchen wir Anschub da wo
Anschub notwendig ist aber ich bin
großer Freund davon dass wir mal über
die Struktur reden weil wir können nicht
mit Geld immer jeden jedes Problem platt
schmeißen sie haben sich zu Recht gesagt
wie diskutieren seit Jahrzehnten um
immer das gleiche Thema das kriegen wir
nicht gelöst also packen wir Steuergeld
obendrauf das kann ich die Antwort sein
deswegen müssen wir auch wieder lernen
mehr schneller und günstiger zu bauen da
geht da müssen wir an die Standards wir
ein ein Beispiel
dann lassen wir da genau
welchen Standard schreiben wir jetzt
zurück er will sagt ja auch zu Recht
Mensch soll mir jetzt mein Brandschutz
sparen oder ganz konkrete Beispiele also
Brandschutz ist ein verhetzungsthema
trotzdem bin ich der Meinung wir müssen
mal drüber reden
dann kommt irgendjemand und sagt du
willst noch
abonnieren völlig absurd wir können das
nicht rational diskutieren aber wenn ich
nach Österreich schauen die haben
genauso wenig Brand tote wie deutschen
aber ein ganz anderes Brandschutzsystem
das viel günstiger ist als es deutsche
die schauen sich an das ist auch stehen
bleibt dass die Feuerwehr gut hinkommt
fertig was wir machen ist weit drüber
wir bauen die dicksten oder mit die
dicksten Betondecken in Europa weil wir
die härtesten Lärmschutzauflagen haben
und dann müssen wir auch mal lernen
wieder mal günstiger zu bauen es muss
nicht immer das Beste vom Besten sein in
Österreich lebt man gut in Frankreich
lebt man gut in Großbritannien in Polen
lebt also weniger würden sie würden sie
damit gehen
wir müssen drüber reden wie wir
ich versuche herauszufinden woran wollen
wir jetzt sparen wenn wir die Auflagen
wenn uns die zu hoch sind müssen wir
irgendwo sagen woran wir sparen wir
müssen mal anschauen was ist weit über
dem Niveau das wir brauchen wo können
wir es runter setzen Lärmschutz
Brandschutz
also also wir gehen alle mal davon aus
dass der Preis der Markt verlangt wird
dass der auch mit den Erstellungskosten
zu tun hat das ist die Annahme hier der
Test aber gar nicht überall der Fall sie
wissen selber dass man sehr
unterschiedlich bauen kann auch zu
unterschiedlichen Preisen also da sind
auch Dinge über die wir jetzt gar nicht
geredet haben nämlich die
Gewinnsituation die Rendite Erwartungen
sind alles Dinge die dabei eine Rolle
spielt sie können heute eine Wohnung für
4000 € pro Quadratmeter verkaufen und
die gleiche Wohnung für 10.000 € pro
Quadratmeter das heißt also das ist ja
dann doch der Vorwurf direkt an Herrn
Bäcker die Gewinne so habe ich sie jetzt
verstanden
ich sehe nur am Markt am Markt sehe ich
dass es Leute er hat ja auch gesagt 12
bis 14 € kriegt er sogar noch hin da
gibt's Leute die sagen ja wir brauchen
18 Euro anders geht es gar nicht wir
können nicht immer alle über einen Kamm
scheren es gibt Leute die bauen zu Preis
zu niedrigen Preisen und es gibt Leute
die haben eine höhere Gewinnerwartung
vielleicht ist das Grundstücke verdienen
sie gut mit der Wohnungskrise in
Deutschland
kostengünstiger Wohnungsbau um das noch
mal hier an dem Tisch mit dem Baum nach
dem gewinnen das ist ja wichtig also
Mieter auf der einen Seite die Gewinne
wenn der Wohnungsmarkt eingeschlafen ist
dann sprudeln die Gewinne nicht mehr das
ist ja wohl eine logische Form wir
können weiter existieren aber das ist
jetzt ne nicht baut und nicht verkauft
kann auch keine Gewinne genau
kostengünstler Wohnungsbau noch mal
einzupacken es gibt nicht die eine
Schraube kostengünstig die man dreht
sondern es sind 1000 kleine Schrauben
die man drehen muss man muss überall
Prozess optimiert man muss an den
Dämmstoffen sparen man muss überall
reingehen und das kann man tun wir
müssen einfach uns mal trauen Wohnungen
die wir vor 15 Jahren oder vor 20 Jahren
gebaut haben die sind heute immer noch
hier freuen sich wachsender
Standard der rein muss das tun also wer
muss Finanzminister die bauministerin
das kann nicht der Bund alleine machen
weil die Länder alle ihre eigenen
Ordnung haben und sich dagegen wehren
selbst wenn Herr Voest Bundeskanzler
wäre kann er nicht anordnen wir bauen
jetzt günstiger
wer muss das wer muss das Lösen also die
Länderminister der Kanzler die
Baumeisterin der Wirtschaftsminister
die müssen alle mal einen anderen Strand
ziehen aber es ist es doch das andere
verschiedene Auffassung
aber das Problem ist die extreme
Verschränkung der verschiedenen Ebenen
die Kommune hat die Planung soweit die
liegt fest da dürfen sie hinbauen das
Land hat die ausführungszeichen was
dürfen sie oder wie müssen sie es bauen
wir im Bund machen die Regelungsrahmen
Umweltverträglichkeitsprüfung Baugesetz
etc und die europäische Ebene ist jetzt
auch noch mal einen oben drauf weil
Deutschland
komisches Verhältnis zur europäischen
Ebene hat nehmen wir das was da oben
kommt und machen nach 120% raus was auch
ein Fehler ist was wir auch korrigiert
was der Bund machen muss und da muss ich
jetzt einmal das sensationelle Wort des
dämmstoffbombers übernehmen das gefällt
mir sehr gut wir haben jetzt das erste
Mal geschafft im Gebäude Energiegesetz
in der letzten kleinen Reform diesen
endlosen Kreisel zu zerbrechen dass man
immer dickere Wände dämmt wenn man
Energie sparen will weil da verbrennen
wir auch unheimlich viel Geld wir
fokussieren uns voll darauf wie dick ist
die Wand wie viel Glasscheiben hat das
Fenster wie dick ist die Decke anstatt
dass wir uns darauf konzentrieren wie
viel CO2 imitiere ich denn und das wäre
im Paradigmenwechsel also weg von der
von den Anforderungen an die Hülle hin
zu der Frage reduziert CO2 Wände
schaffst kriegst ein Bonus Förderung
wenn es nicht schafft kriegsten mal los
CO2-Preis deswegen hattest direkt
Überleitung zu dem Thema das ja meisten
Mieter die meisten und vor allen Dingen
Eigenheim Besitzer im Moment umtreibt
der sanierungszwang der da kommt und das
angekündigte zumindest aus dem
Wirtschaftsministerium geplante Verbot
von Öl und Gasheizung als sie das zum
ersten Mal gehört haben Herr Kaufer was
haben Sie gedacht Verbot von Öl und
Gasheizung also ich bin jetzt
grundsätzlich nicht so ein Freund von
diesen ganzen verboten und Regulierung
und so weiter manche müssen vielleicht
sein aber es wird in den wenn das alles
so umgesetzt werden sollte da einiges
auf Immobilienbesitzer zu kommen in den
nächsten Jahren an zusätzlichen Kosten
die sie einfach nicht eingeplant haben
und da werden möglicherweise viele auch
ihre Eigenheime verlieren ja es ist zu
viel auf einmal denke ich dann haben wir
die Inflation die Zinsen welche werden
sich die die die da sind die Sie
vielleicht vor zehn Jahren gekauft haben
und jetzt verlängern müssen eventuell
auch nicht mehr leisten können also da
kommt noch einiges auf die
Immobilienbesitzer zu und da muss was
dagegen getan werden das ist ja brutal
was sie so locker in dem Nebensatz
gesagt haben da werden die Menschen ihre
Kredite nicht mehr gewinnen können das
ist das eine durch die im Moment so
drastisch steigende Zinsen da werden
Menschen massenweise Menschen
möglicherweise die Häuser ihre Häuschen
ihre Altersvorsorge abstoßen verkaufen
müssen das ist das womit Sie rechnen
damit rechne ich zum Teil ja nicht auf
breiter Fläche aber auf jeden Fall zum
Teil es kommt aber auch hinzu dass
natürlich viele die sich geplant hatten
jetzt mein Häuschen zu erwerben auch gar
nicht jetzt zur Zeit in der Lage sind
aufgrund der Situation und es wird
insgesamt nicht einfacher und ich würde
mich interessieren ob die Bauwirtschaft
sich mal mit dem fertigbauelementen
auseinandergesetzt haben denn da gibt es
da auch Möglichkeiten schneller und
kostengünstiger zu bauen wir müssen doch
nicht immer nur auf Stein auf Stein
bauen dann gibt es ja schon Vorschläge
und gute Ideen in dem Bereich wie
sieht's denn da bei Ihnen aus
also wir haben uns natürlich dem Thema
serielle modulares bauen ihr stellt und
machen das auch aber die Erfahrung zeigt
einfach dass diese je höher der Grad der
Vorfertigung ist also jedem modularer
sich nachher einzelne Wohnungen auf dem
auf dem Transporter lade und in
irgendeine Stadt fahre umso teurer würde
bauen noch das günstigste bauen ist
immer noch seriell vor Ort bauen mit den
normalen Bauarbeitern das ist immer noch
das günstigste bauen aber trotzdem
gehört die Zukunft dahin weil wir
natürlich die Prozesse in der Fertigung
von der Baustelle Weg verlagern in
Hallen und damit die Belästigung für die
Anwohner auch in Deutschland
andere Aussagen ne die sagen
mittlerweile ist es schon insgesamt
günstiger wir waren beim Thema Klima
Sanierung und es ging ganz konkret um
das Thema Verbot von Öl und Gasheizung
und sie sagen das könnte massenweise
dazu beitragen dass die Menschen ihre
Kredite jetzt aktuell wegen der Zinsen
nicht bedienen können und dann raus
müssen aus ihren Häusern wird das die
Koalition also die genau das
verantwortet den Menschen ihre
Altersvorsorge nimmt ihr kleines
Häuschen nein natürlich nicht keiner
wird Oma tschuldigung keiner wird Oma
Erna die Heizung abschalten und keiner
wird er in der Regierung in die Richtung
gehen dass man das Haus verkaufen muss
deswegen haben wir den Vorschlag als FDP
im Haus habe ich auch gestoppt wir
müssen losgehen nichts tun ist keine
Option mehr der Gebäudesektor ist für
30% des CO2-Ausstoßes zuständig man
braucht 40% der Energie also wir müssen
was tun doch was wir aber nicht tun
dürfen ist das was die Europäische Union
macht sanierungszwang also 40% der
Gebäude innerhalb der nächsten 10 Jahre
zu sanieren ist völlig absolut völlig
absurd und diese Angst die auch jetzt
dieser Entwurf aus dem
Wirtschaftsministerium geführt hat man
würde da Menschen überfordern und
Heizung abschalten das ist das ist ein
Bärendienst am Klimaschutz deswegen
haben wir den gestoppt wir müssen uns
auf den Weg machen gemeinsam Schritt für
Schritt man kann mal kleine anfangen
smarte Thermostate die die Heizung
ausstellen wenn Sie das Fenster
aufmachen allein das bringt schon zehn
zwölf Prozent Ersparnis und so müssen
wir Schritt für Schritt anfangen unseren
gebäudestand zu aktivieren und da muss
der Staat auch helfen das ist vollkommen
klar mit der Brechstange durch die Wand
über Nacht ist überhaupt keine Lösung
erleben Sie die Angst auch bei den
Menschen die sie vertreten also nicht
nur bei Eigenheimbesitzern sondern eben
auch bei den Mietern in Deutschland
erlebe sehr unterschiedliche Situationen
es gibt auch bei Eigenheimbesitzern sehr
viele die genau wegen dieser Ankündigung
sagen oh es wird offenbar Zeit dass wir
was tun und dass die sich jetzt Gedanken
machen über wärmepumpeneinbau übernah
Wärmekonzepte sowas gibt es alles und
das sind ja Leute die das positiv
aufnehmen weil sie sagen ja wir wollen
weg von dem fossilen Energien Gas und Öl
und wir wollen eine Umstellung machen
wir brauchen das weil wir in die Zukunft
denken da gibt es eine ganze Menge Leute
aber natürlich ist es auch eine soziale
Frage das ist doch kein Thema und die
Frage ist ob jemand sich das leisten
kann es wird gerade
ältere Menschen zum Beispiel werden auch
im Eigenheim oder auch in der Wohnung
weniger daran Interesse haben weil sie
wir natürlich sagen ich mache das
vielleicht für meine Kinder meine Enkel
aber letztendlich die Investitionen sind
enorm und die Investitionen sind
tatsächlich sehr enorm weil die
baukostenanstieg sich auch bei
Wärmepumpen und bei diesen ganzen Krams
natürlich auch bemerkbar macht deswegen
wird es eine große Herausforderung aber
ich finde dass wir tatsächlich eine
Perspektive für alle brauchen wir sind
für einen Stufenplan in denen die er die
energetische Sanierung inklusive der
wärmewende umgesetzt wird ich bin auch
der Auffassung dass man CO2 als ein sehr
wichtigen Parameter nimmt aber
gleichzeitig auch natürlich sehen muss
dass die Energie die verbraucht wird
reduziert wird weil wir werden nicht die
selbe Menge Energie die wir jetzt Fossil
Waren werden wir nicht mit erneuerbaren
Energien zur Verfügung stellen können
das werden wir nicht hinkriegen ist
meine These ich glaube das ist ich
glaube nicht dass das funktioniert wird
das heißt wir müssen auch gucken dass
wir in den Gebäuden weniger Energie
verbrauchen
dafür kommt dann die Dämmung in Frage
und das muss nicht immer wahnsinnig
kostenintensiv sein es ist es ja häufig
okay aber beides ist aus meiner Sicht
notwendig und dann muss es
sozialverträglich sein aus meiner Sicht
mit einem Stufenplan wir haben schon
2010 ein Konzept vorgelegt das in fünf
Jahren immer die schlechtesten Gebäude
sozusagen dran sind und die auch in den
Genuss von öffentlicher Förderung kommen
wenn die finanzielle Situation der
Eigentümer nicht ermöglicht das hätte
man schon machen können jetzt kommt die
EU mit einem ähnlichen Modell wie wir
vor zehn Jahren schon vorgeschlagen
haben sie haben gerade heftig
widersprochen von der Seite Herr Voest
und sagen glaube ich nicht dass wir viel
viel Energie viel weniger Energie in
Zukunft zur Verfügung haben werden
müssen ist es richtig also wir bauen
massiv der neue Bahn aus die Grünen
erklären mir jedes Mal jede
Sitzungswoche wenn ich in Berlin bin es
ist endlos Energie da Sonne Wind you
name mit und dann sagen Sie mir aber wir
haben nicht genug Energie für alles
andere es kann nur eins von beiden
Stimmen so wir brauchen natürlich
erneuerbare Energien auch in der Nähe
Gebäudes am besten im ganzen Quartier
solaranlagern aufs Dach auch
Solarthermie diese ganze Spielarten
Biogas Hackschnitzel übrigens auch
dekarbonisiert das Glas da jetzt müssen
wir alles gleichzeitig machen aber der
Fokus allein auf die Frage wie viel
Energie verbraucht das Gebäude hat die
letzten 15 Jahre nicht funktioniert nur
zwei Zahlen reingeworfen die
Volkswirtschaft die Gesellschaft
insgesamt hat in den letzten 15 Jahren
500 Milliarden Euro in die energetische
Ernährung investiert und trotzdem
verliert der Gebäude Sektor immer die
Ziele weil wir auf das auf die falsche
Messgröße schauen deswegen auf CO2
schauen und nicht nur auf die Frage wie
viel Energie da reinkommt einfach so
hochgesetzt ja das ist das Ziel ist ja
eigentlich
20-500 Wohnungen die gebaut werden
sollten also auch da möglicherweise die
Ziele aber ich werde mich dagegen dass
ich den Ehrgeiz niederlegen nur weil
schwierig ist ein Ziel zu erreichen
also natürlich wäre das schön und das
ist ja auch das was wir als FDP in der
Regierung machen die bauministerin auch
treiben
es nicht zu erreichen ist die Wahrheit
ja wir schaffen es gerade nicht ja das
ist korrekt aber deswegen sage ich doch
nicht wir reduzieren das Ziel da
verstärke ich lieber meine Anstrengungen
und dann müssen wir an vielen Schrauben
drehen und ja wir haben
Umsetzungsprobleme bei den
baukostenkommissionen ich mache das
jetzt auch erst seit zehn Jahren die
Ergebnisse die liegen vor wir müssen uns
umsetzen und das ist die Rolle der FDP
in der Regierung die baumministerin und
eine Wirtschaftsminister zu treiben
steht dahinter am Ende nicht die grüne
Version das das Eigenheim in
Auslaufmodell sein soll das kleine
Häuschen zu Hause auf dem Land das eben
nur von zwei Personen oder von einer
vierköpfigen Familie bedient bewohnt
wird ist das ein Auslaufmodell in den
Köpfen viele grüne also die Grünen haben
gespannt das Verhältnis zum 21
Familienhaus das ist bekannt aber es ist
nicht Aufgabe der Politik den Menschen
Träume zu nehmen ist ja erst Gegenteil
der Fall müssen ja möglich machen und
ich glaube drei Viertel aller Menschen
wollen ins Eigentum und davon auch viele
die Idee Einfamilien oder
Zweifamilienhaus zu haben was für
allerdings hinbekommen müssen ist die
Fläche clever zu nutzen in anderen
Ländern Irland wächst der wohnt auf den
ich brauche mit meiner sozialen
Situation und singt wieder ich heiratete
meine Wohnung wird ein Stück größer ich
kriege ein Kind Wohnung wird größer die
Kinder ziehen mit kleiner egal
zu zweit in einem Haus das ist
möglicherweise in den Köpfen einiger im
Moment regieren dann Auslaufmodell haben
sie ein schlechtes Gewissen nein
zu Recht nicht ist auch keiner Modell
also wir haben ja einen Bestand von
allein in Berlin gibt es 260.000 ein
Familienhäuser also wie kann man davon
Auslaufmodell sprechen es gibt einen
hohen Prozentsatz von Menschen die in
solchen Wohnformen Leben Punkt so und da
will die will auch niemand was wegnehmen
aber die müssen sie am Klimaschutz auch
beteiligen das ist doch gar keine Frage
auch beteiligen heißt dass es so teuer
wird dass man wirklich bezahlt wird
könnte man in der Regel verbrauchen
diese Menschen ja auch sehr viel
Wohnfläche wenn diese Menschen so viel
Wohnfläche verbrauchen müssen sie auch
akzeptieren dass sie Anforderungen
ebenfalls erfüllen das kann nicht sein
dass wir Mehrfamilienhaus die
Anforderungen alle erfüllen müssen aber
die Einfamilienhaus also das müssen wir
mal ganz kurz übersetzen er will das
bedeutet nämlich dass die Oma die
alleine noch in dem Häuschen wohnt dass
die so viel Wohnfläche im Moment bewohnt
dass sie sagen dann muss sie auch mit
den Kosten klar kommen die da in Sachen
Klimaschutz auf sie zukommt ja das ist
doch klar wenn ich in eine
Zweizimmerwohnung mit 60 Quadratmetern
wohne und muss irgend eine Sanierung
dort gemacht werden ist das natürlich
viel billiger als wenn ich alleine oder
zu zweit auf 180 Quadratmetern wohne
dann wird das automatisch wahnsinnig
teuer das ist doch logisch also von
daher ist es vollkommen klar die müssen
die dürfen nicht ausgenommen werden aber
es ging ja hier um die Frage des Neubaus
bei der Frage ob die Grünen mit den ein
oder zwei Familienhäusern was macht und
da geht es darum ob wir und das war ja
der Hamburger Fall da ging es ja darum
dass praktisch in innerstädtisch in
einem Quartier was immer noch zur
Innenstadt gehört tatsächlich ein auf
einer bebaubaren Fläche
Einfamilienhäuser akzeptiert wenn Ja
oder Nein und da der zuständige baut
gesagt wir wollen an dieser Stelle mehr
Familienhäuser und keine einfachen also
alleine in der Villa geht nicht mehr
sagt auch der Mieterbund das wollen sie
nicht
es wird immer Leute geben die sich eine
Villa bauen können darum geht's gar
nicht sondern es geht dafür in der
Breite der Bevölkerung hinreichend da
stehen sie aber dahinter das ist nicht
aus ähm
von von die ganzen alle Kommunen werden
das so machen wenn Sie heute bei der
Wohnungsnachfrage die wir haben können
wir doch jetzt nicht stellen Sie sich
mal vor hier am Berliner Hauptbahnhof
wir hätten da rundherum lauter ein
Familienhäuser gebaut es geht doch gar
nicht nein das ist ja absurd ja genau
nur sie sie sagen ja auch bei Omas
kleinem Häuschen das ist doch ganz klar
dass dann besonders hohe Kosten auf sie
zukommt das ist so sagen sie ausziehen
aus dem Haus sein das kann gar nicht
zahlen die viele werden ja auch das
Kapital haben die Investition zu tätigen
wenn Sie es nicht haben es gibt
öffentliche Fördermittel die die ja in
Anspruch nehmen die nehmen die Bar
vermittel die KfW Mittel die nehmen die
alles in Anspruch aber wer so viel
Quadratmeter Fläche hat der wird
natürlich nicht vermeiden können dass
dieser Sanierung dann auch teurer wird
das ist doch klar Kampf also alleine ein
Haus zu bewohnen in großes Haus zu
bewohnen das geht nicht mehr das darf
nicht mehr sein
ja das hat wirklich nicht mit dürfen zu
tun
die Klimaziele erreichen ich bin jetzt
ist ja immer viele Sachen gleichzeitig
das eines der Flächenfraß das andere ist
die Umweltbelastung das dritte ist die
Klima Frage wie viel CO2 und wir müssen
die Klimaziele erreichen völlig ohne
Fragen und da muss jeder wir schrauben
nicht mehr geschraubt wir schrauben
nicht am Preis also tatsächlich was das
Wirtschaftsministerium vorgelegt hat
wären Überforderung von vielen ein
Zweifamilienhäuser aber auch von vielen
größerem standhalter aber wir müssen uns
trotzdem auf dem Weg machen mit
Förderungen mit Unterstützung mit
technologieoffenheit man muss ja immer
mal sagen alle anderen Länder setzen
oder viele andere Länder setzen auf
Wasserstoff setzen auf Technologie
setzen auf dekarbonisierung von Gas
setzen natürlich auf die Wärmepumpe oft
wenn sie günstigen Strom haben haben wir
momentan nicht nicht so trotz wir müssen
alles möglich machen uns auf den Weg
machen und da ist jeder Eigentümer in
der Pflicht der kann er sich nicht
rausnehmen werden Anreize setzen Energie
wird teurer werden CO2 bekommt einen
Preis und der steigt weil wir müssen es
wegkriegen wir haben Untersuchungen
gemacht darüber wie viel Eigentümer
öffentliche Fördermittel im Rahmen der
energetischen Sanierung in Anspruch
nehmen das sind mehr Familienhäuser
zugegebenermaßen des Mieterbundes ja da
war der Anteil der Eigentümer die
öffentliche Fördermittel in Anspruch
genommen lag bei fünf Prozent das
spricht erstmal für die gute
Wirtschaftlichkeit der Eigentümer denn
sonst hätten sie ja vielleicht die
Fördermittel in Anspruch genommen ok
aber ich will damit sagen diese
Strategie mit öffentlichen Fördermitteln
Anreize zu machen die ist gescheitert
seit Ewigkeiten und deswegen ist es
vollkommen richtig dass die EU endlich
eine Energieeffizienzrichtlinie vorlegt
die tatsächlich auch zu einer
Verpflichtung führt meines Erachtens was
ist Pflicht schließen wir dann diese
Gebäude das ja die nächste Frage bei sie
haben dort einmal ganz am Ende der Blick
in die Glaskugel er wählt ganz kurz an
alle Mieter dort draußen in Deutschland
die jetzt Bild schauen was würden Sie
sagen wo stehen wir in drei in fünf
Jahren mit Blick auf die Mieten haben
die sich noch mal erheblich verteuern
vor eins ist vollkommen klar wir werden
tatsächlich für die Aufgaben die wir
haben mehr Geld ausgeben müssen es wird
mehr Geld kosten allein der Klimaschutz
wird mehr Geld Kostensteigerung aber wir
werden natürlich auch dafür sorgen
müssen und das muss die Regierung tun
das hinreichend Fördermittel zur
Verfügung stehen um das also viel
deutliche Verteuerung aber Förderzentrum
Einkommen wird man im Schnitt fürs
Wohnen aufbringen müssen 40% 50% und
mehr wie jetzt schon viele Deutsche so
wenige wie möglich wenn wir das ist
keine Antwort es gibt keine pauschale
Antwort ja wir sind 84 Millionen
Deutsche und da kann man nicht für jeden
sagen also es darf niemanden überfordern
ist der Punkt deswegen haben wir das
Wohngeld erhöht wir investieren 14,5
Milliarden Euro und sozialen Wohnungsbau
als Ampel aber wenn wir das System nicht
ändern wie wir arbeiten dann machen wir
es unnötig teuer deswegen müssen wir
eine Systemfrage haben wir werden
dutzende Milliarden zur Verfügung
stellen und wir werden auch dafür sorgen
dass sie bei den Bedürftigen ankommen
und nicht bei denen die es nicht
brauchen aber wir müssen das System
ändern müssen schneller mehr und
günstiger ich danke Ihnen
für diese Runde hier an diesem Tisch
eine Runde die öfter in dieser Sendung
selbst gezweifelt hat an der
Veränderungsfähigkeit des Systems an
tatsächlich ja dem System das
bezahlbares Wohnen für uns alle schaffen
soll ich danke dennoch herzlich für
diese Runde Bäcker erfüllt werden danke
Ihnen der Welt danke Ihnen Herr Gau war
wir sind zurück nächsten Montag hier bei
Bild danke
[Musik]